the treatment of the RO Hanja minority
in Myanmar equates to genocide that's
the conclusion made by the UN the
mission has concluded that criminal
investigation and prosecution is
warranted focusing on the top tat Madore
generals in relation to the three
categories of crimes under international
law genocide crimes against humanity and
war crimes with ethnic cleansing
happening on the watch of Nobel Peace
Prize laureate own son su Qi and despite
public demand to rescind Chi's award the
Nobel Committee insists she should keep
it
[Music]
the UN report demands Myanmar's top
generals be investigated for crimes
against humanity it also accuses miss
Chi of turning a blind eye to it all but
that's alright because the Nobel
Committee says it's only concerned with
what happened in the past it's important
to remember that a Nobel Prize whether
in physics literature or peace is
awarded for some prize worthy effort or
achievement of the past and sang su Chi
won the Nobel Prize for Peace for her
fight for democracy and freedom up until
1991 the year she was awarded the prize
well if we're to believe the committee
only cares about recipients pasts
they're gonna have some explaining to do
here yes sir Arafat received the Peace
Prize for brokering a Middle East Accord
securing Palestinian rule in Gaza and
the West Bank at the same time he was
the chair of the Palestinian Liberation
Organization responsible for violence
against Israeli civilians who they
considered to be part of an illegal
occupation Arafat did renounce the
violence before receiving the award
though but how about another Nobel Peace
Prize laureate Henry Kissinger
Kissinger received the prize for
negotiating a ceasefire in the Vietnam
War he was set to share the nomination
with North Vietnamese diplomat lay
ducked all except the Vietnamese
responded with a big no thank you and to
no one's amazement
that's because Kissinger had been
secretly bombing Cambodia throughout the
1970s as disclosed in a Pentagon report
he approved almost 4000 bombing raids in
just the first two years of the campaign
and last but not least is Barack Obama
many were left puzzled as to what Obama
had exactly done to receive his Peace
Prize but just like the others the Nobel
Committee said it had something to do
with his past only very rarely as a
person to the same extent as Obama
captured the world's attention and given
its people hope for a better future
we are not awarding the prize for what
may happen in the future but for what he
has done in the previous year we hope
this will enhance what he is trying to
do what exactly Obama did in that
previous year is a mystery to most
people
you